tonight new video into out front of embattled
Republican Congressman George Santos making
even more questionable claims this time in
a Brazilian podcast which was just released
but actually was recorded two weeks before his
laundry list of lies about his education work
history Family Life religion were first
exposed right so this was back when he
didn't know anybody knew that all that was
false so these new claims we're finding out
include that he was mugged in Manhattan which
an NYPD Source says there is no record of that
he survived an assassination attempt and
that he'd donate his entire congressional
salary to charity which today he refused to
say he would still do Eva McCann is out front
embattled Congressman George Santos back at work
on Capitol Hill today dodging tough questions from
reporters as New Revelations about public planes
he's made continue to pile up judge the latest
coming from a recently released interview with
a Brazilian podcast that was taped in December
shortly after Santos won election in New York's
Third District Santos claimed in the interview
done in Portuguese that he was mugged on Fifth
Avenue in New York City in the summer of 2021
as he was walking out of a commercial building
in broad daylight they robbed me took my bag my
shoes and watch but a source with the New York
Police Department tells CNN there's no record
Santos reported the alleged crime the lack of
report doesn't mean the alleged incident didn't
take place but it draws further scrutiny of
the claim made by by Santos who has already
admitted to lying about key parts of his biography
another claim Santos made in the interview that's
raising eyebrows that he survived an assassination
attempt we have suffered life attack assassination
attempt threatening letter having to have security
guards and police escorts standing in front of our
house but Santos did not go into any further
details or provide any corroborating evidence
in the same podcast Santos suggested he was living
comfortably enough to make a pledge to donate his
congressional salary to charity he declined
to answer questions about that vow on Tuesday
the 34 year old did say he would cooperate with
a potential upcoming house ethics investigation
Santos wasn't among his colleagues at the
new member reception this evening at the
White House though he was invited I just
didn't have the time it was on my schedule
constituent Services Santos already facing
questions about his future plans including
whether he'll run for re-election
wow it's so early for that question
and Aaron I spent the day asking Santos's
Congressional staff about the many claims
he made in that podcast interview despite my
best efforts did not get a response meanwhile
the concerned citizens of New York three
that's a bipartisan group organized though
by a Democrat they're continuing to turn up the
heat now calling on Republican conference share
Ali stefanik their fellow New Yorker to use her
leadership position in the GOP to push Santos out
Aaron Eva thank you very much and I want to go
now to Flora Thompson Devoe she is the director
of research for radio novello and produced that
podcast interview that you just heard with George
Santos so Flora I really appreciate your time and
I guess I want to start off with you know we laid
out the timing right you did this interview with
Santos after he won but before the world knew that
all these things were lies but you heard him
telling you all these stories what were you
thinking as he told you this yeah that we did
um the story was pitched to us at novello by a
reporter at Poe magazine Jean Batista Junior
and he and and we were really interested in
Santos as a character you know as this person
who came from the background that he came from
who arrived at the values that he arrived at
who's made this you know impressive uh has
had this impressive career or ahead at that point
in time so we sat down for an interview with him
and when we came out of it I I
thought we didn't have a story
um it was sort of a blend of cliches platitudes
uh these really unsatisfying talking points Jerome
was particularly interested in uh the George's
George Santos's comfortable life and uh he he
uh sort of reacted to any questions that we had
by calling them Indiscreet about his finances
um but in general it just seemed like it was
a blend of sort of some there was some fake
news some fabulism and I made the Judgment call
that we didn't need to give this guy more oxygen
um and well by now that that that quickly
became a moot point right but interesting
when you say you felt that there was fabulism
I mean some of the things that he said and as
you point out that every time you asked about
finances he said Indiscreet tried to punt it or
walk away from it I mean I feel like that's a
really significant details that you're sharing
um when when he talked to you about his
congressional salary um he obviously promised
to donate to charity and it wasn't just a
throwaway thing like I'm going to journey
to charity he laid out to you specifically how he
was going to do it let me just play that Exchange
it's 174 000 a year which I've even
decided I'm not going to receive I'm
going to receive but I'm going to donate
so I have already chosen four ngos to
which each quarter I will be delivering
a check for the net profit of my salary
okay incredibly specific he's picked four ngos
every quarter they're getting a check so then
today uh he was asked about that very promise that
he made on your podcast and here's what he said
do you still plan to do that
do you think any charity will ever see that
salary unclear um in the same story we also
spoke to uh the man who was on the receiving
end of the bad checks that uh Santos uh wrote
in 2008 and he upon hearing that Santos was
planning to to donate his salary said that he
would like to be put on a list of potential uh
recipients so there's that so I want to play a
little bit more of what he said to you about
that alleged mugging in Midtown Manhattan I
just want to be clear he said it happened in
broad daylight walking out of a commercial
building that he was robbed right it was and
it was near Trump Tower here's what he said
it was in summer of 2021 on Fifth Avenue and
55th I was robbed by two men before you ask
they weren't black they were white for that matter
they robbed me took my bag my shoes and watched
so robbed him his bags shoes and watch obviously
that's that's a searing experience and it's very
specific uh an NYPD Source tells CNN though that
there's no record of him reporting in mugging what
do you make of that Flora I mean it's one of my
favorite exchanges in the new any of you just
the way that Jean Bautista just asked so they
took your shoes in the middle of Fifth Avenue
you know it was it didn't pass the smell test
immediately and I don't know it struck us as
um almost a fable or perhaps a Horror Story
meant to make a point about how bad crime is
in New York and afterwards I was looking around
and he hadn't told this story up I found him
telling it uh to one other show but I I kind
of reasoned that the reason he might be well I
thought you know if this happened to him uh why
hasn't he spoken about it more because you know
crime you know Rising crime was a big part of
his platform so that doesn't really make sense
and then I thought maybe he's choosing to tell
it to us now uh because uh he thinks that maybe
it'll pass the smell test for a Brazilian
audience who's less familiar with New York